considera las moléculas representadas
arriba y los datos de la tabla de abajo
aquí arriba tenemos la estructura del no
nano y la estructura del 234 tree
floruro pentano que es un poco difícil
de decir entonces lo voy a abreviar como
de fp y aquí tenemos esta tabla con
datos ok el 'no' nano y el 2 343
fluoruro penta no tienen casi la misma
masa molar
128 y 126 gramos por mar pero él no nano
tiene un punto de ebullición
significativamente alto aquí podemos ver
que él no nano tiene un punto de
ebullición de 151 grados celsius
mientras que para el t fp es de 89
grados celsius cuál de los siguientes
enunciados ayuda a explicar mejor esta
observación bueno antes de ver las
opciones que tenemos pensemos
rápidamente en qué es lo que significa
que algo tenga un punto de ebullición
alto
o bajo miren el punto de ebullición nos
dice que tanta energía necesitamos
agregar para romper las fuerzas internos
leku lares entre las moléculas entonces
un punto de ebullición alto significa
que tenemos más fuerzas inter
moleculares que superar
entonces lo que realmente nos están
preguntando es cuál de estas opciones
explica por qué el non a no tiene más
fuerzas inter moleculares a comparación
del t fp vamos a ver la opción a nos
dice el enlace carbono flúor es más
fácil de romper que el enlace carbono
hidrógeno bueno sabemos que esta es una
respuesta incorrecta porque no tiene
nada que ver con las fuerzas internos
leku lares así que esto no explica nada
sobre el punto de ebullición ahora la
opción b dice que el enlace carbono
flúor es más polar que el enlace carbono
hidrógeno bueno podemos ver que el té fp
tiene estos enlaces carbono flúor y
sabemos que el enlace carbono hidrógeno
no es tan polar y que el flúor es muy
electro negativo entonces este enunciado
es verdadero
verdadero pero no explican lo que sucede
con el punto de ebullición
entonces si decimos que el enlace
carbono flúor es más polar que estos
enlaces estamos diciendo que si el té fp
tiene enlaces más polares entonces tiene
fuerzas inter moleculares más fuertes
pero en ese caso tendría un punto de
ebullición más alto y eso no ocurre aquí
así que aún cuando el té fp tiene
enlaces carbono flúor que son más
polares en realidad tiene un punto de
ebullición más bajo por lo tanto esta
observación que es verdadera no explica
lo que necesitamos saber ahora
la opción se nos dice que las cadenas de
carbono son más largas en el no nano que
en el 2 343 fluoruro pentano bueno si
analizamos las estructuras
esto también es verdadero verdadero en
el non a no tenemos 123456789 carbonos 9
carbonos contra 1 2 3 4 5 contra 5
carbonos y como podemos vincular esto
con el punto de ebullición bueno sabemos
que aún cuando la masa mola es casi
igual la longitud de la cadena la
longitud de la cadena está relacionada
con las fuerzas de dispersión de london
entonces conforme la longitud de la
cadena aumenta eso significa que las
fuerzas de dispersión de london
es decir que las fuerzas internos leku
lares que ocurren cuando tenemos dipolos
instantáneos esas fuerzas también
aumentan entonces como este compuesto
tiene una cadena más larga tiene más
fuerzas de dispersión de london porque
estas moléculas están más disponibles a
interactuar entre ellas con sus tipo los
instantáneos y por lo tanto si esas
fuerzas aumentan el punto de ebullición
aumenta y eso es lo que estamos tratando
de explicar entonces la opción c es la
respuesta correcta pero vamos a ver la
opción de para asegurarnos de que no
estamos tomando una mala decisión solo
para verificar la opción de dice las
cadenas de carbono están más separadas
en el no nano que en el 2 343 fluoruro
pentano bueno en realidad no sabemos si
esto es verdadero o no pero vamos a ver
si este enunciado fuera verdadero nos
explicaría lo que sucede con el punto de
ebullición
si las cadenas de carbono están más
separadas en el nora no separadas
significa que entre más separadas están
más débiles son las fuerzas internos
leku lares y esto significa que el non a
no tiene fuerzas inter moleculares
débiles y por lo tanto tendría un punto
de ebullición más bajo punto de
ebullición bajo y nuevamente eso no es
lo que estamos tratando de explicar
porque sabemos que tiene un punto de
ebullición más alto esto tampoco explica
los puntos de ebullición así que la
respuesta es la opción c